mario paul has been embattled besieged
and bombarded
the strategic port city subjected to
indiscriminate attack by artillery and
from the air since the war started in
february
the russian assault here likely to be
one of the focuses of the international
criminal court's investigations into war
crimes
from the very start this campaign has
been one of extreme brutality and it's
got worse over time this is
unfortunately entirely consistent with
the russian way of war that we've seen
in previous campaigns in syria
and before that in chechnya in the two
chechen walls
nigel gould davis is an academic
specialising in the former soviet union
he was previously the uk's ambassador in
belarus so the fall of mario paul
is that going to be a game changer it is
important it does
i think uh further the russian
uh aspiration to establish some kind of
longer-term control over that southern
coastline of ukraine
and
is clearly consistent with the
re-forming the drawing back and
redeployment of russian forces we're
seeing across ukraine which is a
consequence of their their failures
further west of course they're
regrouping but mario paul will be an
important part of that the basis of that
new campaign
in western capitals putin's war so far
is seen as a major strategic failure but
people are also aware of the lessons
from chechnya and from syria if you're
prepared to use the most brutal brute
force whatever the cost to civilians or
even your own troops you might prevail
in the end
there is an important date on the
horizon may the 9th is victory day the
commemoration of the defeat of the nazis
in russia in the second world war some
fear president putin will plan a new
offensive so he can turn the tide of the
ukraine war before this symbolic date in
his country james bays al jazeera london
some refugees from ukraine are looking
for shelter beyond europe more than 3
000 of them tried to cross the border
from mexico into the u.s last month rob
reynolds reports on that from california
i'm on the u.s side of the u.s mexico
border right over there is tijuana and
we have been seeing a steady stream of
ukrainian migrants coming through here
and making their way to the united
states you can see here they're
they're talking to relatives they're
they're taking a rest we spoke uh just a
few moments ago to several ukrainians
who had just arrived here in the united
states
very happy and
very nice but we
was very
tired
because
long
way now all of this is being organized
by volunteers they're coming from
ukrainian churches and social groups as
well as
people who have no particular connection
to ukraine but just thought that it
would be a good thing to volunteer and
to help people out and we'd like to talk
now to mark ribacov
mark you're the coordinator of this
volunteer effort tell me what you've
been seeing
in terms of ukrainians coming across how
many and
you know what what condition they're in
so
over the past roughly a month
we had a ramp up period initially
it was a slow beginning and then we had
about 200 people cross over in a 24 hour
period
but the latest trends were having about
1100 people across the border in about
24 hours so it's increasing it's
increasing and the wait times at the
border uh have decreased significantly
so we're providing the bare essentials
anything that would uh
in to fill the immediate need if people
are
have a need that need will be met
immediately
mark thank you very much for speaking
with us okay now one of the reasons as
mark mentioned that there are there's a
very short
waiting time for ukrainian migrants on
the mexican side is that the u.s has
waived
the requirements that were imposed under
president donald trump called title 42.
that was a policy that allowed for
immediate expulsion of migrants so all
the ukrainians for the most part are
being
brought through processed very quickly
that has raised some questions about a
double standard and some migrants rights
advocates are are wondering about that
as far as the people of other
nationalities who are coming across but
right now right here ukrainians are
touching american soil and they're safe
at last
russia says that it successfully tested
a new intercontinental ballistic missile
called sarmat president vladimir putin
said that it will provide food for
thought for those who threaten russia so
what do we know about this new
intercontinental ballistic missile well
it's been in development since the early
2000s and is meant to replace russia's
aging soviet-era arsenal it weighs more
than 200 metric tons and can carry
multiple large nuclear warheads capable
of hitting different targets in several
locations at the same time
it has a long striking range of around
18 000 kilometers and russia says it
could even fly over the north and south
poles and attack anywhere in the world
fabrice poitiers is a chief executive
officer at rasmussen global he says that
unveiling the sarmat missile isn't quite
the coup that the kremlin might make it
out to be
this is part of a long series of uh what
we call nuclear signaling from
blabbering we put in since the beginning
of this
war in ukraine
where
he's been engaging in both rhetorically
and also in in some kind of measures to
show that he might be willing to use
nuclear weapons if russia were to be
threatened
however this sarmat intercontinental
missile is actually two years late
on on delivery so even though putin is
presenting things as if it's a great
moment for the strength of russia it
actually tells you also about the delays
and the corruption in the russian
armament procurement system and i think
the the the key question here is
whether uh western allies nato allies
are going to respond to what is again as
i mentioned yet again a nuclear
signaling from vladimir putin by saying
that nuclear weapons and weapons of mass
destruction have nothing to do in in the
war in ukraine and the moment they will
be brought in that war it will
fundamentally change the nature of the
conflict and it was already say a few
weeks ago at the nato summit but i think
it does not hurt repeating it that's the
principle of an intercontinental missile
is to be able to hit a target uh tens of
thousands of kilometers away
but i think that what the pentagon also
said is they are very confident in their
own capabilities so i think there is a
an attempt uh implicitly to restore some
kind of stability in the strategic
nuclear deterrent between the two
countries